ouais d'accord c'est très dans notre oh tu
arrête juste ça s'il
te plait hey est-ce que tu plafonnes faisons juste une
pause allons-nous juste dire quelle est la
prochaine
mm-hmm oh celle-ci est Janna Wow
laisse-moi être capable de comprendre Jim quand
la ceinture et Xiao long  dans
Charlaine Freud emboîté le pas comme un pas à moi et
double de quoi tu parles de tennis
Oh tais-toi d'accord je peux gérer ça
Denis elle est follement amoureuse de moi d'accord
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas avec ça
oh elle ne voudra pas m'épouser ou
avoir mes enfants Oh Dennis de quoi
parlez-vous Oh en fait les gars un très
bon point de quoi parlez-vous
Dennis être capable de parler des biscuits quels
biscuits peut-être si je le fais m'aime
un peu tu ne sais pas tellement elle
veut se marier  moi à voix haute là
dans le placard Wow biscuits eh bien je
ne vais pas te donner un biscuit tant que tu
n'auras pas répondu à ma question
d'accord d'
accord Dennis est devenu une
créature à la pensée rationnelle regarde je ne peux pas me
concentrer sur quoi que ce soit jusqu'à ce que j'ai eu
un de ces biscuits je sais que c'est fou
mais c'est comme ça je suppose que je suis un peu
accro à eux alors s'il te plait donne  moi juste
un biscuit alors je pourrai penser
à autre chose hmm
qui a du sens oh oh oh tu prends le
risque car il devient maintenant est le plus
cohérent c'est ça il les a
il les a
woof il les a je '  Je vais juste
jeter sa jupe ça vient hein bon ça doit
être terrible d'être un doc Je n'avais jamais réalisé que
tu avais autant d'envies ce n'est pas pire
que toi dans cette [ __ ] quelle [ __ ]
la [ __ ] tu as baisé la nuit dernière
oh mon dieu ce n'est pas une [ __ ]  d'accord, c'est une
adorable femelle humaine et nous n'étions pas juste en
train de baiser oui tu n'étais pas en fait nous
parlions beaucoup
de baise sais quoi d'autre
y a-t-il à parler de
beaucoup à y penser ça ne me dérangerait pas de
te baiser la jambe bien  maintenant hmm que
diriez-vous d'une petite danse des jambes hm
je suis allez papa je pensais que je t'avais transformé en une
créature à la pensée rationnelle les créatures à la
pensée rationnelle ont toujours des désirs eh
bien nous pouvons zoomer avec cela non
ne m'enlève pas mes désirs pourquoi pas
cela rendrait ma vie digne d'être vécue des
biscuits en train de baiser je  ne pense pas que j'aime
ta conversation mais je t'adore
maître je t'aime tellement
je ne peux pas supporter de te déplaire mon
monde entier s'effondre quand tu croises avec moi
regarde peut-être que c'était mieux quand tu ne
parlais pas Oh non non  m'enlever mon pouvoir de
parler maintenant que je peux penser rationnellement
que ce serait si cruel quelqu'un à la
porte la cloche sur la cloche oh
hé hé quelqu'un là ça
recommence  juste
tais-tu me comprends-tu oui c'est
n'importe quoi pour t'empêcher d'être en colère contre moi
Burke recommence hé hé hé hé Dennis
écoute juste écoute écoute écoute écoute
écoute écoute tais-toi
c'est un ordre bien
ouais j'aime obéir aux ordres surtout
votre ou  c'est bien alors ferme ta gueule
oh bon bon garçon